good news for the national football
league and the national football league
players association they have
self-negotiated themselves some
agreements as we get closer to the start
of training camp and look we know the
nfl is a deadline driven league my
concern was that from the player's
perspective there really wasn't a
deadline hey we'll show up you tell us
what the rules are if we don't like them
we'll file a grievance money-wise
if you don't like what if we don't like
what you're offering we just we're fine
with what we currently have available to
us under the labor deal they have worked
out most importantly a protocol for the
covet 19 testing the players had been
pushing and pushing and pushing chris
sims for daily testing they will get it
for at least two weeks it may then
reduce based upon
how many guys test positive or otherwise
you need to have multiple negative tests
before you're even allowed into the
building if you test positive you either
have 10 days or two negative tests
before you can come back
positive and asymptomatic i think he had
a much quicker path to returning
positive with symptoms it's going to be
a little bit longer but they got the
basics worked out
and and and that's good that's good
because that was one of the primary
impediments to getting a deal done the
union wanted as the nflpa said in a
statement yesterday strongest testing
tracing and treatment protocols to keep
our players safe testing protocols we
agreed to are one critical factor that
will help us return to work safely and
gives us the best chance to play and
finish the season and that's ultimately
what it came down to the players weren't
going to strike right from the player's
perspective if at the end of the day
what gets put into place isn't good
enough what happens
it all falls apart like a jenga tower
and you've only taken a couple of bricks
out of the thing that's what they were
trying to avoid
they were trying let me let me do this
again as we try to force it into the
webster's dictionary they were trying to
self-protect the nfl from itself with
this the concern was that by going maybe
a little cheap
maybe going with a little bit less than
what the nfl should have done right they
were setting the stage for a disaster
that's that's how the nflpa is is
characterizing this not as the product
of a negotiation the idea was we're both
trying to negotiate against the virus we
needed the best testing in place to do
it and the nflpa is happy with where
they are for now yeah they should be i
mean they definitely should be i mean
first off it's it's you know
in a realistic world nfl football i mean
to think that you were only gonna test
two three times a week or something like
that i just don't know how that works
you know i don't and i know that like
teams and and players and everything
they're going to try to practice social
distancing during practice to a degree
but it's not going to be foolproof and
you know again unlike the other sports
it's more of a balancing act in the nfl
well of course we know it's a way bigger
roster the training camp roster because
90 people
so within that too we know there's more
chances so i'm glad the owner stepped up
and i think the point you make about you
know hey the players yeah they didn't
want this thing to self-destruct before
they even got going or got going and
started to get into football shape and
then all of a sudden you got to take a
break and get away for a while wait a
minute what how could you do that
self-destruct itself
come on we're making a push here you had
a prime opportunity i thought i said it
that's why i didn't even realize it i
thought i actually said it
but but um i do think this was a huge
step and this is gonna comfort players
in in a big big way uh i i really do
think that and it was a necessary step
if the nfl wants to make it through
training camp not have this be over
before it starts you know and and start
lumping days together uh i don't see how
there would be any other way to do it
than the way they're gonna do it here
too and the good thing is you know i
know the owners were like you know
worried about the money probably about
the testing and all that but you know i
saw you know some of the protocols right
like yeah it could drop down in two
weeks but if it starts to pick up right
where it's five percent of the team
again they can go back into the testing
and testing every guy every day so
they've really covered themselves in a
lot of different areas that uh make a
lot of sense
well and i've been trying to figure out
exactly what kind of a financial
investment they're getting into and
obviously it's a cost of doing business
at a time when lives are on the line but
my understanding is the deal they have
with bioreference laboratories entails
120 tests per day
per team flat rate across the league
divided up by 32 for all the teams to
play and then if there are any tests
that are conducted beyond 120 per day
they cost 125 each now the way business
normally works you're not paying 125
each for the first 120 it's going to be
some reduced rate then beyond that is
when you get it no 125 a day but they're
turning around the results in 24 hours
or less i still have real concerns about
the nfl draining resources that would be
available for the general public
whether they're doing the actual testing
and the analysis locally at a lab in
south florida or whether they're sending
it somewhere else all the tests that
they're doing for the nfl
are tests that could be done for people
who are actually sick
and and and when you consider or at
least think they're sick i mean nobody's
just going to take how many people are
going to take a tesla yeah i just feel
like having a having a q-tip you know
shoved all the way up my nose no it's
somebody who thinks they may have it
like like you recently did you thought
you may have it so you go get tested and
then when they put me through a
checkpoint my mic they did like i had to
get on the phone and talk to a you know
from my yale new haven you know medical
hospital up here in the connecticut area
they made me talk to a doctor
and give him some symptoms too because
they don't want people just going oh my
eyes itchy i need to go get a coven 19
test right so there was some sort of
protocol to where you just can't abuse
the testing system i guess is what i'm
saying sorry to interrupt
no it's fine there's no protocol for the
nfl i have to be his own a team or a
coaching staff or a trainer or anybody
else that falls into the first two tiers
of access to restricted areas who needs
to be tested every day even if you're
perfectly healthy for five straight
months you're going to be tested every
day the point is there there is and it's
been overlooked because i i don't think
they have a response to this no if they
had a response to it they'd be talking
about it there is an ethical issue here
that's being glossed over regarding the
impact of all of these tests on the
people who can call a hospital and
answer all the questions like you did in
a way that lines them up for a medically
necessary test and with the virus raging
that's a real issue yeah if it was like
it was back in may not a real issue if
it had gone the way we thought it was
going to go between may june and july
not a real issue when you look around
and see how many positive results there
are every single day in various major
cities where nfl teams do business
that's an issue that that i think it's
just one of those things where we really
don't want to deal with it so we won't
but i think it's it's appropriate for us
to raise the question and it's
appropriate for us to ask the question
what are they going to do to ensure that
they're not keeping people who need to
be tested from being tested who need
their results more quickly than five to
seven days from getting those results on
a faster basis chris yeah well that's
what i mean i'm scared of that too
you're right i mean listen i want
society to society to heal first right
and everybody get healthy and let's get
back on the right track you know i'm not
hey like up here in the new york new
jersey area yeah you know i'm you know
the jets and giants gonna be tested
every day but i don't know we're not
having testing problems nor are we
having this huge outbreak i'm more
worried about yeah the arizona the texas
the california the florida teams you
know and you're hearing the horror
stories there about how long it does
take to get the test and the results and
things like that but you know again i i
this to me yes i it seems maybe a hair
insensitive by the nfl and the players
but
i don't know when the federal government
doesn't get involved and leaves it up to
the states and things like that this is
the stuff that happens so you know money
talks bs walks and the nfl's got money
so they're paying a lab to do it all by
themselves and they got their own little
lab to do it all and that's not right
you're right it's not right in our
country but on you know the the reality
is right now in our country that's the
way it is and uh i don't know if
anything's gonna change it at this point
and football fans would say it's
justified to have those resources
diverted to nfl players because we need
football and we want football and we
need the diversion and and that's fine
football fans can take that view and i'm
inclined to take that view of the yeah i
hear a lot of people there's still a lot
of people in the country who don't care
about football and care more about
themselves their family members their
friends people who
may have coveted 19 and there's an
urgency to find out so those people can
be properly treated and properly kept
away from others that they can infect so
it's not an easy question
and the easiest approach so far for the
league in the union has been to ignore
it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports